hey guys hi how are you i'm good
so this show is so addictive uh keith i
read that you said this is one of the
best scripts that you've read in the
past
10 years so what is it about this story
and these characters that you fell in
love with
well again it goes back to the story of
the fugitive which is
you know really centered around
society's
rush to judgment and i think it's
something that we
unfortunately do far too often
but i just i thought it was witty i
thought it was funny
i thought it was dynamic i thought it
was dramatic it had so many
qualities but it also moved at a pace
now the real danger is when you read
something like that it doesn't always
transfer when you go
to put it on its feet uh but this really
did
it was it was one of the
the easiest uh jobs i've ever had
just because the script was such a
strong foundation
it was an absolute pleasure to be a part
of wow that's pretty big coming from you
and you know
the projects and films that you've
worked on you know i feel like your fans
have been
eagerly waiting for you to take on a
role like this you know especially since
24
why do you and the action genre work so
well together
i have no idea you would have to ask
someone
who has watched what i do in that regard
why i've always liked it though i go
back to the films that i loved watching
as a movie goer going all the way back
to 48 hours with nick nolte
and eddie murphy to the french
connection with gene hackman to serpico
with
al pacino all of those films
were the films that i really love to
watch so to finally get
an opportunity as an actor to work in
those kinds of
movies uh in the thriller genre or the
action job
uh have been really exciting for me
uh boyd what was the the whole
atmosphere like on set like does it feel
as intense as it is for us watching it
and what was it like working with kiefer
well shutting down entire blocks in los
angeles and downtown uh
is exciting it's it's on a scale it's
it's pretty grand
um and you know kiefer was one of the
reasons i became an actor
um getting to come full circle and
work with one of your heroes is um it's
a very humbling experience it's a very
exciting experience it's very
comforting experience because you know
that you're in
really good hands with who you're
working with and you know you're giving
that workload and
it's a great responsibility to have to
to try to meet his bar
oh wow well that's really nice and in
all fairness
uh we are friends and and boyd was one
of the real reasons that i was excited
about doing this i was such a huge fan
of narcos
i've seen so much of the work that he's
done over the past
10 15 years that uh again
you know stephen hopkins who directed 24
was the director of this show
uh you know so excited about
the quibby as an idea as a platform
telling shorter stories
um so there were all of the elements
seem to come together
to make this project uh what i believe
it is which is special
now like you were saying before you know
so many of us know the fugitive you know
the 90s movie the show from the 60s why
do you think viewers are really going to
connect to this new version of the
fugitive
well i think of this one as kind of the
post 911 version of the fugitive
terrorism has hit u.s
soil technology has grown leaps and
bounds to the degree where there's
cameras and video
on every street corner in any major city
in the us
uh that can all be manipulated uh and it
is in this show
and and so as we tend to as a society
rush to judgment
in certain things uh and this goes back
to the lynch mobs of the early
you know late 17 early 1800s to to now
um it's a lesson for us to learn to take
our time and find out the facts
there's a reason why people are presumed
innocent until they're found guilty
we should follow our own advice and and
it's
so it's kind of a moral lesson in that
regard and i think as an audience person
uh when you know that the person that is
being chased is innocent
uh you can't wait to see the look on the
face
of the people that are doing the chasing
uh when they realize they're wrong
and and you root for that and you want
that and so
hopefully that's what we've accomplished
uh and
that's why we chose to do it yeah well
congratulations on the show i've seen
the first four episodes so now i just
can't wait to see the rest of it so
congratulations very nice talking to you
to boyd
you